simplifique x cuadrada menos 4 x 4 x / x
4 menos 3 x 2 factor hicimos estas
ecuaciones cuadráticas para ver si
podemos cancelar algo
luce bastante sencillo que no menos al
sumarlos me dan 4 y al multiplicarlos me
dan menos 4 pues menos 2 en el numerador
voy a tener x menos 2 por x menos 2
hagan las operaciones si no me creen
esto va a estar dividido entre que par
de números al multiplicarse dando si a
sumar se dan menos 3
ambos tienen que ser del mismo signo
pues al multiplicar se van a dar
positivo y ambos deberán ser negativos
para que al sumarse de negativos esté
menos 3 pues menos dos y menos uno menos
dos por menos uno es dos y menos dos más
menos uno es menos tres así que va a
estar dividido entre x menos 2 por x
menos 1 y asumiendo que x nunca va a ser
igual a 2 oa uno para que eso lo queda
indefinido después verán que en la
gráfica este punto aparecería como un
hueco porque está indefinido se cancela
esto con esto y me queda que las
simplificaciones x 2 entre x menos uno
que es la opción a pasemos al siguiente
problema el problema 67 que esto sea
kubica menos 20 a al cuadrado entre 16 a
cuadrada más 8 ha reducido a su mínima
expresión bueno vamos a factorizar el
numerador y el denominador a ver qué
sale
vemos entrada que en él
numerador estos dos términos son
divisibles entre
4 a cuadradas lo vamos a factorizar 4 a
cuadrada 12 a kubica entre 4 a cuadrada
va a ser igual a 3a
- 20 a cuadradas entre 4 a cuadrada va a
ser igual a 55 por 420 a cuadradas se
conserva así que esto es igual y como
les digo si no me creen pueden hacer
esta operación para que vean que es
cierto ahora del denominador vemos que
estos términos son divisibles entre 8
ahora sacamos 8 a los factor izamos 16 a
cuadrada entre 8 a va a ser igual a 2a y
8 a entre 8 a es igual a 1 más 1
qué más podemos simplificar aquí 4 entre
4 va a ser igual a 18 entre 4 va a ser
igual a 2 esto es un medio a cuadrada
entre a esto se elimina y aquí nos va a
quedar a solamente aquí ya no podemos
simplificar más y esto va a ser igual
soy parte de arriba nos queda por tres a
menos cinco entre dos x
a más 1
es la opción de bueno vamos a ver el
siguiente problema que es el problema
resuelva 7z al cuadrado 7 z entre 4 7 8
todo esto por seth al cuadrado menos
cuatro entre z cúbica +12 está cuadrada
maceta
mientras me parece muy complicado de
resolver pero yo creo que debemos
factorizar lo más posible y ver que
tantas cosas se pueden cancelar
este primer numerador vemos que es
divisible entre 7 c está ambos términos
vamos a factorizar lo de esta parte
vamos a escribir
7 z que multiplican 7 z al cuadrado / 7c
está me va a quedar solamente set
7 z / 7 se esta va a ser igual a 1 muy
bien aquí ya factor izamos esto y
continuamos con este otro numerador
cuando estamos multiplicando fracciones
simplemente es multiplicar numerador con
numerador y multiplicar denominador con
denominador así que voy a seguir con
esta parte esa parte se está cuadrada
menos 4 luce como un a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada así que esto me va a quedar
como z más 2 por zeta menos 2 z menos 2
y eso es de todo el numerador ahora
vamos a analizar el denominador
aquí puedo factorizar el 4 así que sería
4 por 4 z entre 4 queda zi8 entre 4 va a
ser igual a 2
de este otro veo que puedo factorizar z
todos estos términos contienen una zeta
así que esto lo puede multiplicar por
zeta
z kubica / z va a quedar como z cuadrado
más 12 está cuadrada entre zetas queda 2
z más se está entre z que digo a la 1 y
creo que esto aún podemos factorizar lo
más esta parte de aquí de entre
paréntesis esto de aquí lo podemos
factorizar más de hecho esto nos
quedaría como z más 1 por setama zona
y lo multiplicamos nos da lo que está
aquí dentro del paréntesis
ahora vamos a reescribir todo esto para
que quede bien voy a ponerlo en otro
color también para que se vea más
atractivo el numerador nos queda
7 z lo voy a escribir por acá 7z por z +
por z 2 por zeta - 2
ahora de el denominador
lo reescribimos 4 por z 2 por z por esto
de aquí abajo
z 1
por amazon
y ahora viene la parte divertida vamos a
ver que podemos cancelar este z se va
con este otro z
se está más uno se va con este otro se
está más dos se va con este otro y creo
que ya no podemos reducir más así que
esto nos queda igual a 777 me parece se
está no no es eta es un 7 con
describirlo bonito 7 por 7 menos 2
/
4 por z más uno
qué es la opción y el siguiente problema
es el 69 nos piden encontrar el producto
de esa fracción x 5 entre 3 x + 2 x 2 x
3 entre x 5 haciendo mucho que es
simplificar así que vamos a hacer las
operaciones como les comentaba cuando
multiplicamos fracciones se multiplica
el numerador por numerador y todo eso se
divide entre el denominador por el otro
denominador lo reescribimos tenemos
x 5 x 2 x 3
en el numerador y tenemos
3 x 2
por x 5 y ahora vamos a hacer estas
multiplicaciones
x 5 x 2 x va a ser igual x x 2 x 2 x al
cuadrado 5 x 2 x va a ser igual a más 10
x
ahora 5x por menos 3x por menos 3 es
igual a menos 3 x 5 x menos 3 va a ser
igual a menos 15
dividido entre 3 x + 2 x x 3 x x x es 3
x al cuadrado 2 x x es
+ 2x
3 x + 2 x 5 3 x x menos 5 va a ser 3 x 5
15 x y 2 x menos 5 va a ser menos 10
ahora vamos a simplificar esto tenemos 2
x no tenemos otro término con x al
cuadrado así que nos queda 2 x cuadrada
10 x menos 3 x va a ser igual a 7 x + 7
x
y aquí nos queda menos 15 no lo
reducimos más
ahora trabajemos el denominador el único
término al cuadrado es este nos queda 3x
al cuadrado menos perdón los 2 x menos
15 x nos va a quedar menos
x
-10 y esta es la opción de ahora pasemos
al último problema de este vídeo el 70
que es una división cuando multiplicamos
una fracción por algo es lo mismo que
multiplicarla por el recíproco de ese
algo así que esto es lo mismo que
multiplicar x cuadrada más 8 x
+ 16 / x + 3 x 3
por el recíproco de esto que el
recíproco es x cuadrada menos 9 entre 2
x + 8
debemos y podemos simplificar esto un
poco más el numerador de esta parte lo
podemos factorizar cómo voy a escribirlo
acá
x 4
este x cuadrada menos 9 luce como un a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada así que esto
es igual a x
+ 3
x 3
muy bien y ya tenemos nuestro numerador
factorizar ahora vamos con el
denominador aquí el x + 3 cuando podemos
hacer la gran cosa este se conserva x 3
y este 2 x + 8 pues vemos que podemos
factorizar el 2 2 por 2 x entre 2 nos
queda x + 8 entre 2 es igual a 4
y aquí factor izamos lo más posible y
nuevamente esta es la parte divertida
donde podemos cancelar términos
tenemos x4 se puede ir con este x + 4
este se queda x 3 se va con este x + 3 y
nos queda que esto es igual a x + 4 x +
4 por x + x x menos 3 entre dos aquí nos
quedó el denominador solito un 2 y es la
opción se nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo